I like when they cut to Taylor Swift I
mean I don't know I like to see that no
football fan well for us men who are not
that masculine we need to see Taylor
Swift at the game we we need some in the
game yeah you know what I can make a
good argument it's a lot more exciting
to see Taylor Swift because I know
what's going to happen in the football
game they're going to throw the ball
they're going to kick the ball they're
going to run back and forth guys are
going to score I know what the game is
let's see some variables let's see how
Taylor Swift reacts let's see if she
talks to Patrick mahomes's wife let's
see how she's getting along with Travis
Kel's Mom let's see if Travis Kel's
brother comes in and starts running
around with his shirt off I like to see
that right John you like it I love the
Taylor stuff I I think it's I think it's
great I think it's great for the game I
think it's great for her I think it
makes it entertaining